Buying stocks makes those investors partial owners  in the business.
Their investment helps the company to grow...
...and as it becomes more successful,...
...more buyers may see potential and start buying stocks.
As demand for those stocks increases, so does their price,...
...increasing the cost for prospective buyers...
...and raising the value of the company's stocks people already own.
For the company, this increased interest helps fund new initiatives...
...and also boosts its overall market value...
...by showing how many people are willing to invest in their idea.
However, if for some reason a company starts to seem less profitable,...
...the reverse can also happen.
If investors think their stock value is going to decline,...
...they'll sell their stocks with the hopes of making a profit...
...before the company loses more value.
As stocks are sold and demand for the stock goes down,...
...the stock price falls, and with it, the company's market value.